the Joe Rogan experience incremental
steps to robot ageing of reality reality
is going to be either virtual or you're
going to have a combination of virtual
and augmented and you're going to
probably be overtaken by robots I think
that [ __ ] Unabomber guy was right
yeah Ted Kaczynski you know that guy
[ __ ] cooked his brain What did he say
well he thought that technology was
gonna take over the human race that's
why I was killing all those people that
were involved in technology I have a
theory that with the escalation of our
like climate you know whatever that and
I heard this panel back in 2000 it was
like I remember being it was all about
the nature of the soul and is the soul
essentially and human consciousness
essentially going to jump elements from
carbon to silicon in order to survive
the wasteland that we're gonna leave
there's something gonna happen and I
think Trump was on extra adderall when
he's like I know what to do I'm gonna
buy Greenland I think he was on to
something
I think that was like probably the best
[ __ ] idea that he ever had I wish
people got more excited about it because
he came up with it and like it was
dismissed and it was in and out of the
news cycle in like four or five days
green land was like [ __ ] you he's like
alright but I mean I don't know he could
buy a green land but if you could and
that was like America Northeast like
where is Greenland on the map Northwest
northeast way northeast right yeah so if
he was like that's American northeast
just like Alaska Hawaii we got a new one
that's a [ __ ] great idea cuz when
[ __ ] gets really warm and people start
moving there and like guys this is the
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] 78 degrees you can
defend it huh I mean how big is
Greenland how huge big enough for all of
us could it be American Northeast really
really listen put on the screen the size
of Greenland
first the u.s. yeah let's what do you
think never mind
oh well I I don't wait never mind a
continental US are we including Alaska
Alaska makes laughs its way more yes
alaska's and nor but nobody lives there
like three people live in Alaskans
sorry Alaska we love it was way bigger
alaska's bear they are barely Americans
they're awesome don't get me wrong I
mean they live in Paradise that's like
true size is what it says mm-hmm
but holy [ __ ] it's huge yeah I know but
when you drop it there it fits right in
the middle so yeah but that's bigger
than Texas yeah dude Texas could fit
everyone in America Wow look at the size
up there yes
Texas assume people don't realize how
big australia's australia's pretty big
it's as big as the contiguous united
states hmm but there's only as many
people as less less than as many people
as los angeles and look at this one
right that's great look at the
perspective oh [ __ ] well how does it
look
isn't that crazy when you see the actual
position it looks way bigger the United
States something but then when you oh
that's because of like taking a round
thing yeah yeah that's so stupid I don't
know what to do that matter there's no
Toja doesn't work
[Applause]